how are you doing today sir doing good
good to see you steve
nice to see you uh let me start with
congrats on the movie uh i it's a blast
i hope it's a huge hit for you guys
sincerely thank you
uh i tons of questions for you um i want
to start with who how do you rank uh
shang chi's power level in comparison to
say like a hulk or a thor do you view
him as more powerful did you ever debate
this
it depends uh if you're talking about
the beginning of the movie or the end of
the movie
um uh i i think he by the end of this
movie i think he is
you know standing standing up on on a
similar level to some of our our
favorite superheroes in in the mcu
um
but yeah i mean for fun we've debated
things like this but i don't i don't i
don't really know the answer to it but
i'm sure we'll explore them in the
future
100
this is your first movie of uh on this
scale and scope what did you learn
making this film that you wish you knew
on day one
i wish i knew on day one um
to just chill out a little more i was
like i was really scared in the
beginning um you know we we started off
with some big
big sequences um with with a lot of
extras and we were primarily shooting
legendary tony liang and so that's where
i started
and it was really terrifying for me
because i i wasn't
um
used to working with tony yet i was
i was really i was really i felt i felt
really uh out of my element but
it really was within that first day that
everything settled and i realized that
i'm i'm surrounded by a a really
supportive team and
that what we were what we were making
was
really fun it it turned into
one of the most pleasant exciting
exhilarating experiences of my career
and it was it was a blast to work on i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie what do
you think fans would be surprised to
learn about the making of a marvel movie
or the making of shanghai i mean i was
surprised
at how fluid ideas flow
amongst
other other productions on on that are
happening within the mcu
um and the how fluid ideas are
are flowing within our own production
and the the evolution
of
of the story
over the course of the two years that
you're making it um
was also
really surprising how how much
things are constantly changing and
updating and becoming better and better
and better really with the fans in mind
from day one all the way to the end
we're just constantly trying to make the
movie the best it can be
so it's the the most exciting thing for
for all of the fans and that was
that was a a really cool part of the
process that i wasn't fully aware of
was there anything that almost ended up
in this movie that was maybe cut for
time or budget or whatever reason
there was a really cool fight scene um
that was set in a really cool setting
um
that i don't want to speak out loud
because i really hope that we can do it
in another movie um but
but it was one of the most
uh exciting settings that that um
i was hoping hoping to see a
a a fight scene happen in um but i and
and it didn't make it into this movie
but i'm i'm pretty sure it'll make it
into the next one
i always ask filmmakers this question um
how long was your first cut compared to
the finished film that fans will see
i think the first cut was close to three
hours um
and
and the the final cut is is a little
over two hours
um but the the the changes that happen
between the first and the final were
were
fairly
we
we went through quite a few changes and
rearranging things and you know our
movie is telling some linear story story
lines um and
and to find the the real
balance of of the
the
you know
revealing of information and the drama
was something that we really discovered
in the editing room with our incredible
team of editors
now obviously when you say three hours
that's probably like an assembly cut
that's literally all your footage yeah
so i guess my question is did you end up
with a lot of deleted scenes or was it
um just tightening the scenes you had no
we have a lot of deleted scenes that
you'll be able to experience on the
blu-ray or however they release deleted
scenes now got it really some really
good ones i think there's some great
deleted scenes in this one
would you say that it's like 10 20
minutes or less than that
uh
i don't know
that sounds close to right i don't think
it's less than 10 minutes now i'm
definitely curious about the
post-credits scenes um was it always
those two scenes or did you almost have
something else
there was always some version of those
two scenes that were floating around um
the the post-credit scenes are always a
discussion up until the very end so
there's so many what if what if
scenarios flying around
um that that may be you know exciting
teases of what's to come
there there were some much more
elaborate pitches
uh
for for some of those scenes um but i'm
really happy with where we where we
ended up
the without getting into spoilers the
first post-credits scene
poses a question it sort of is asking
what is
something's happening if you will when
you do something like that do you
already have the answer or the sort of
like let's just pose this question we'll
figure it out later
it's a little of both i mean we we
definitely are are posing a question
that is pointed to a direction that
makes sense to what's happening in the
um in the mcu
but and also is is a direction that is
very exciting for us to explore in the
future um
but the
the questions that are
left unanswered are are equally as
exciting i think to the creatives making
the movie as it is to the fans i think
exactly what fans are going through or
what we're going through like all the
potential what ifs of what what it could
be and that's kind of that's part of the
fun of working for a studio like marvel
i have to stop i'm just going to say
again congrats on the movie and i
sincerely hope it's a massive hit thank
you so much